can you give us like an introduction of
your background how do you get into
crypto especially I think a lot of
students doing the pre-class uh question
collection we're very curious about your
background being like more into
photonics like PhD there and how do you
navigate into a D5 space
um
yeah wow uh that's uh I guess that's a
hard question to start with already
um yeah so what why uh why D5 from like
weird physics Quantum unclear
um I think
uh so I I was into like crypto very very
early on uh because I had a really cool
graphics card uh back in 2010 I had the
coolest graphics card in fact I was like
I had like learned about this like thing
and I was like wow I can like play
whatever video games I want on this
Graphics I promise it's gonna get back
to the what something actually useful
but right now bear with me
um and uh you know after
you know what do you with the coolest
graphics card well you play all the
coolest video games at the highest
settings and then you know the coolest
video games with the coolest Graphics
are all very boring right uh because
they you know everyone focused like 100
of their time making cool graphics and
zero percent of their time actually make
them interesting
um so then uh the next thing that
happened was a friend was like hey you
can like mine this magical internet
money using your like fancy graphics
card uh and I was like what what are you
talking about like again remember the
timeline this is 2010 uh for context uh
Bitcoin had just come out in 2008
October of 2008 right uh and at the time
there was this like weird you know thing
Bitcoin which you could just like
magically Mine by solving a bunch of
like really hard problems on your like
really cool graphics card uh and so I
did that and then you know much like the
video games and it's not very
interesting to just like watch a number
go up on your computer and then have it
be really loud and hot in your room
um so that that was my foray into crypto
and approximately like three days after
mining whatever some hilarious probably
very small of our maybe not so small
amount of Bitcoin
um which is forever lost to the ether uh
that was like that was it
um and then I had a crazy
boss
in
2016. uh called tarun chitra I don't
know some of you maybe are familiar with
them if you if you're around crypto
Twitter
um you're probably somewhat familiar uh
this crazy dude with like crazy blue
hair well I guess now it's green no no I
think it's yellow actually but anyways
um oh I might no actually no no it's not
red yet but it should it should be uh
maybe that's the next one I'll I'll let
him know about it
um so here's my ex boss of this like
weird company that we did like weird
math for protein folding but the point
is he was really into this thing called
ethereum uh he was like this thing is
really cool and I was like what are you
talking about like ethereum like what
does this mean it's like you can program
like anything you want and just like
have it run on like The Ether
uh and I was like haha ethereum either
okay fine
um and uh from there it kind of devolved
uh into just like
hanging out and trying all these like
cute little weird things
um and then afterwards in 2018 my then
ex-boss tarun
um came back and he's like hey you know
remember that ethereum thing yeah I'm
doing this crazy thing called Gauntlet
which is like this crazy company that
like at the time was simulating how
blockchains interacted with each other
and he was like also there's this thing
called uniswap
I don't know how many of you have heard
of Unison but of curiosity just if you
could like raise your hands just for fun
okay so about 50 so uniswap at the time
was this like insane idea which is
um you could go on chain and like trade
assets for other assets without
requiring any intermediary
this is like very weird right like
markets usually work in like one
specific way they work because like you
Matt you have a bunch of people who like
all want to trade you know they're
willing to buy something for a given
price and some people are willing to
sell it and you're like cool you gotta
Market
unisoft did not quite work this way
um so anyways at the time
uniswap had this it was a crazy contract
and it had was an insane amount of money
in it like five million dollars which is
like hilarious by our standards nowadays
but at the time it was a lot of money
okay you got to trust me on this and for
some reason or another we decided that
like you know who the hell is going to
put five million dollars into like this
crazy like 200 line piece of code that's
like vaguely running on some like
magical internet computer right in order
for people to like trade
um and so that was the the beginning of
the journey with tarun specifically
actually that was a foray and we started
writing a bunch of papers
um which at the time you know was funny
because it was hard to get anyone to
read them and I guess now it's clearly
you know something happened in the
middle because in 2018 you know I would
tell people about you know something I'd
be like what the hell are you talking
about and now I guess there's a 250 how
many people are here uh roughly 200 okay
200 person class that's quite full uh of
people hearing me blabber on about weird
markets so um I guess that tells you
that difference between like 2018 and
2022 and that was that was the initial
foray into into crypto and like weird I
guess paper writing at the time so
um why for photonics to crypto it turns
out it's kind of
if you squint enough it's all the same
math
um so from from physics you learn a few
things from math you learn a few things
and it turns out like those are very
very useful tools which we can get into
later but but
um I think uh maybe I don't know
hopefully I don't want to make anyone
fall asleep quite yet that's for five
times from now
all right okay thank you for the angel
an interesting journey into uh crypto
and D5
um that being said um we'll start with
some like
um basic question to level set um on the
defy and then dive into more kind of uh
interesting question about the future
and probably some potentially some
skepticism around default as well and
then towards the end we're probably like
15 minutes or so um open the floor um
for questions so if any question or any
point that we discussed feel free to
um like whenever we have the open floor
or raise your hand ask questions cool
right cool I'm worried about the
questions by the way but it's fine all
right the first question is
um just to level set can you give your
view of uh decentralized Finance right
why do we need decentral Finance how is
it different from the traditional
Finance
oh man uh okay
um so I guess what is decentralized
finance co-locally known as defy
colloquially sometimes known as magical
internet money
um
okay so so well I mean maybe maybe like
this is going to get weird and
philosophical too quickly so I'm going
to try to not to but
um what is finance right it's like a way
of like kind of taking a bunch of
different assets or things and like
grouping them in various ways right in
order to like package up risk this is
like again like this is like stepping
back you know 50 million steps we'll
probably cut something Concrete in a
second
um D5 is you know if you have a
financial system what's like a natural
thing to do well it's like naturally you
should be able to like trade within this
financial system you should be able to
like loan things you know you should be
able to like buy things
um so D5 is just like one incarnation of
that in the context of blockchain
right like fairly simply it's like what
happens if you like in order to do
things on chain you have to be able to
like interact with different assets
interact with different protocols Etc
each of those protocols might require
for some reason you know their own token
might require any number of things maybe
it's good for you to not actually you
know buy the token maybe it's better for
you to like you know borrow the token
and so just kind of naturally as an
outgrowth of like having a cool
Financial magical internet money
platform the next thing to do is like
make a cool magical Financial like
magical internet money Finance thing
that you could like lets you kind of
trade or you know like use your money in
a more efficient way right rather than
just like buying it and holding it or
buying it and giving it to other people
right so it's kind of like
the highest level of D5 what is D5
nowadays I think it's mostly uh a
collection of trading platforms lending
platforms uh certain options protocols
some of which are kind of weird I don't
know how many people are familiar with
options here but you know just like
traditional financial instruments uh and
then a bunch of other things that
actually are like very
shockingly odd I think like one of them
is called like squeeth or something
which is uh you know these these are
things that you that are
let's say difficult to do in traditional
Financial systems
um
other than by kind of writing a hundred
Page Long contract but it turns out you
can do them just using some basic math
you can actually construct them fairly
easily
um
so that I mean that's what Defy is now I
don't know what D5 will be in the future
but that certainly is what like 90 of D5
is now maybe I'm forgetting some
protocol here and there but like maybe
some fixed splending or fixed income
things but they're fairly minimal I
think in the when compared to
uh you know the volume of trading and
the volume of lending I think which each
have many many tens of billions of
dollars
um currently like today like you can go
on check it out
um so hopefully that answers the
question I don't know if I missed a
second question in there did I or I
think you answered the the question okay
Define general like uh high level and uh
kind of why do we need a design right so
so what do we need defy I mean kind of
you know you when you have a financial
thing you want to make like your money
work for you in some sense or another
right like you can't like it's cool to
like have
again I will refer to like I guess the
problem with magical internet money is
that it's like now an overloaded term
because someone actually used it to like
as their token name which is really
silly but whatever the point is like you
have this thing that exists and you can
just like hold it but like what if you
could you know actually do other things
with this asset right and so you know D5
is the is the natural next step of maybe
I can lend that asset out to someone
maybe I can trade it for other things
maybe I can you know construct some
crazy like elaborate thing with it I
don't know that's that's the that's the
you know level zero answer to why one
might need defy
um there's other things too but maybe
maybe we'll get to those in the spicier
questions sure um
um all right thank you uh for kind of
describing defy um like kind of high
level
um so I'm just curious based on your
um personal
research all your research uh quizzing
Bing Capital crypto what's your either
your personal view or if you as a
organization part of the research team
like some of the gaps you see in the D5
ecosystem and uh some interesting future
trains you say this hard is for see the
future but new thing will be interesting
that might form part of D5 3.0 is very
like we're in Stanford I think a lot of
students are very curious
um doing some sort of startups so okay
ideas potentially oh man
um
um
I guess if I knew what D5 3.0 would be
I'm not sure I would be here I would
probably be uh you know hopefully making
it or you know having someone else make
it well I mean maybe maybe all of you I
don't know if you're not careful at
least
um so I guess maybe maybe it is good
that I'm here but unfortunately for you
I do not know what D5 3.0 is so I I have
no active free Alpha to give here
um
to
you know I can give like a very
obviously biased version of what I think
D5 3.0 will be um which to me is like
much more exciting
um but okay so
kind of stepping back right again
weirdly
all of these protocols like exist right
and they're like some smart contract on
some chain
and fundamentally like the entire point
of this whole exercise of
decentralization is
well it's like you know you you make
Bitcoin because you like don't want to
trust any one Authority
right you like the whole point of
Bitcoin the whole reason why like we run
all of these like very complicated
machinery
right in order to like make sure that
everyone is in consensus and like it's
very expensive it's very difficult right
the reason why we do it fundamentally is
because like we want to be decentralized
and unfortunately
a good amount of defy right now is not
decentralized
like it relies on specific
intermediaries kind of called oracles
telling you the truth so in other words
telling you like what the price of an
asset is how does one construct you know
certain payoffs how does one like create
certain loans and how does one like
liquidate them Etc
so
okay or liquidity the collateral
whatever but so right now in some sense
we have we've like built this like
insane machine right that like solves a
bunch of really hard problems from
computer science and now we've built
stuff on top of it
right and like this stuff on top of it
is like great because it works pretty
well like 99 of the time but then every
once in a while right like this question
of like trusting this like weird
Authority telling you the truth right
that you need you
you currently need to construct these
protocols like that's a very bad
assumption to make and it ends up
failing
right so I think the you know defy to I
guess maybe D5 3.0 or two I don't know
which of what whatever version we're
currently at right now like actually
we'll get rid of those intermediaries
the problem of course is that it's very
easy to build things when you assume
that you know the truth it is very hard
to build things when you don't know what
the truth is and you have to discover it
yourself in other words like when you
don't know what the price of the asset
is and somehow your protocol must like
learn the price of the asset in some
sense without relying on someone telling
you what that is is much much harder
than just being like yeah look I just
like query like cool little you know set
of like people telling me that the price
of you know ethereum is like 1300 right
now or whatever versus like creating a
protocol such that everyone's incentives
are aligned in such a way that you don't
actually need that in the first place
um so that's that's where I hope D5 will
move in the future and there's been a
bunch of uh I don't know if you've been
following the current uh you know crypto
Twitter ramblings there's been a bunch
of attacks essentially
no using the notion that these you know
people can kind of manipulate these
prices fairly fairly easily and so you
can cause a bunch of protocols to break
so that's where I think D5 is is you
know hopefully moving into in the near
future
um but it's very hard it's very very
difficult because it's not just a hard
engineering problem it's a quite
difficult mathematical one too
um
so that's that's the you know High first
version of that
sure thank you for sharing uh with us
your your view
um another question could be uh is also
related to the Future which is like a
lot of students actually very curious
It's like defy I think I checked
actually uh three hours ago oh no
um kind of if you use around the metric
like a total value block which is like
total amount of money or ethereum or
whatever token equal in US Dollars
locked in protocols D5 really protocols
that's a metric we use to measure like
D5 protocol it's around 50 billion
dollars and then that's your although
sounds impressive it's still very very
small compared to additional miners
which is like trillions or tens of
trillions
um what's your view that's missing for
those big uh organizations the
traditional Finance to get into the
space
if they ever will consider right would
you consider anything they would
consider second is if it's a consider
what's missing I'm sure it's being
considered I I don't see why not right
like it's yet another kind of possible
inflow of
we'll take cash or assets or any another
way of diversifying your portfolio et
cetera whatever you'd like whatever you
know fancy excuse you want to like make
for yourself as a big company to like
you know make more money
um
I think there's a few things that are
difficult
about defy the kind of most glaring
problem is that it's very slow and I
don't mean slow as in like oh it's like
slow moving and like people aren't like
improving on it a lot no I mean like
slows and like it's literally slow like
in order for you to make a good number
of transactions on you know ethereum
like good luck you're going to pay a lot
of money and you know even that is going
to be like quite capped so that that
already kind of rolls out
a good amount of you know high frequency
trading relative to like other things
although people still do it and this is
like a longer topic that we can get into
um later probably over Pizza actually
um
so that's that's one part number two is
um I think a lot of kind of big
companies are fairly risk-averse right
and it's like the second that you have
an asset that you know goes down 30 in a
day uh usually if a stock market goes
down like you know three percent in a
day there's like a bunch of like
Breakers that like all go up and you
know Everyone likes hair is on fire and
like we're running around and like the
whatever the trading floor you know on
the other hand like
assets going down 30 a day is like yet
another day in you know in in the life
right which is fine I mean it's cool
it's it's insane that we build systems
that are like resilient so like things
going down 30 or so and so that's kind
of this is like the very slow moving
funds are like very risk-averse in that
sense
um I of course think there's some some
regulatory questions about like how do
you you know
you're like a pension fund that's
managing a bunch of money like you can't
just like ape into like a bunch of like
D5 protocols right that's probably very
weird
um I unfortunately have no actual like
you know notion of the law so then of
course I'm not a lawyer but like my
point is like kind of there's a lot of
regulatory like
you know there's no Clarity here so it's
very hard to know like how to actually
interact with these things in a way
that's like legit and cool with the law
and then finally I think it's just kind
of honestly really damn hard to use like
defy right now is like really freaking
hard to use
like interfacing with it constructing
things on it like using it in a useful
sense like you should I mean
I'm sure you all can figure it out but
let's say my grandma probably will not
be able to like figure out how to take
out a loan on Ave with her like you know
whatever Sheba token as collateral or
whatever I mean whatever you're into
right like there's just no way the
probability like is roughly zero not
that actually you can do that on Navi
well I hope you can't actually that
would be very bad but anyways so I think
I think all of these things like
contribute like fairly deeply into this
problem of like
holy crap like yeah sure there's like
this system which is like very small
relative to you know traditional Finance
but at the end of the day it's still
like another thing to do
um you know like why kind of we don't
have like these bigger companies kind of
coming in and like using it you know as
yet another income stream or something
like this
um but again you know I unfortunately
I'm I'm not particularly good friends
with like people in Citadel and stuff so
um you know I would not be able to
actively tell you these things okay
thank you quite uh insightful all the
different views around uh how to have
the mainstream adoption or tri-fi
adoption yeah
uh so now I think we're gonna navigate a
little bit more into the deeper
skepticism spicy questions okay I wonder
if I have good answers for this so one
question is around um you mentioned like
I think a lot of big institutions they
have concernable regulation like the
fact is slow and the volatility Etc et
cetera but another problem that actually
kind of a blocker if you think the
future is like everything's problem
programmable
um like composed of Etc but they also
make it easier or relatively easier or
much easier for hackers to hack and they
can just one person with no money do a
flash loan and pull off like hundreds of
millions of hacks in just one person
that's right out of nowhere in his
personal computer
um so once you review
um that part the vulnerability if you
become super composable and super
um kind of um capitalization so by the
way this is like actually before we can
get to that this is like possibly one of
the most insane things in the world I've
does everyone know what flash loans are
like
does anyone not know what flash loans
are
okay at least one okay there's a good
number this is like actually the most
like ridiculous thing in the world by
the way just like let's let's touch on
that first before we get through this
this will enable the next conversation
you know it's like a like a prereq in
the like Tech Tree or whatever
um okay so flash loans are essentially
an instantaneous loan for any arbitrary
amount of money
the only promise you have to have is
that you repay the loan
after your transaction is completed so
okay what happens in let's say ethereum
you have a transaction you call a bunch
of things for example you do a bunch of
swaps you take out a bunch of loans
whatever you'd like right
a flash will enables you to do the
following it says at the beginning of
your transaction which is composed of a
bunch of different things doesn't matter
what it is
you're allowed to borrow as much money
as you'd like I will give you as much
money as you'd like with a promise that
at the very end of your transaction you
have paid back all of the amount
potentially with a bit of a fee but
let's actually for for a lot of things
it's actually free so you don't even
have to think about the fee
okay so what happens
the transaction goes on the blockchain
right let's say it gets accepted by
someone
and then it gets executed
so you start let's say I borrow 10
million dollars I don't have to have any
collateral I just I am simply allowed to
just like take the money
you know and then do a bunch of stuff
with it
so okay so I like I've been given 10
million dollars I do a bunch of things
in the middle and if at the end of a
transaction I've paid back my 10 million
dollars the transaction goes through
and it's as if everything was you know
everyone was happy because you paid back
the transaction everything happened
great we're all happy okay
if something happens in the middle and I
cannot pay back the 10 million dollars
the transaction reverts and it is as if
nothing had happened in the first place
so in some sense it is a riskless loan
that I do you know that someone has
given me
that is enabled by the fact that you can
like program this thing and then the
transactions execute what are called
atomically they execute either all at
once or not at all
all right this is like crazy by the way
this is like this is like possibly the
most like insane thing that I don't know
like this is like this does not exist
anywhere in traditional Finance there's
nothing similar to this original Finance
like you know like if this doesn't kind
of blow your mind like there's there's
two doors over there you should probably
get out right like this is Bonkers okay
so why do flash loans fine okay so now
we're we've got that Crown settled which
is crazy oh sorry I didn't actually mean
that I promise
um
but okay that's fine
um anyways so uh okay so fine so so you
know what why are flash loans use over
hackers well the quick version of it is
look if I can loan 100 million dollars
like with absolutely no collateral
requirement and I could pull off a hack
for example one thing you can do is you
can borrow 100 million dollars push the
price of an asset up
right and then cause things you know
things for example uh things that depend
on the price of that asset to like
happen to Cascade right and then if it
just so happens that that gives you a
bigger profit than you started with and
congratulations like you have pulled it
off and like you now have like more
money than you started with so you just
pay back the loan and you've made a free
profit okay
so
um in some sense this is you know flash
loans are very seem like a very bad idea
because it's like okay wait you're just
given like you know every 10 year old in
their mom's basement like the ability to
just like go and play around with
protocols until like they make some
profit I mean they're they're expensive
on ethereum so I wouldn't you know
actually recommend doing this but
um but on the other hand you've kind of
done something also like weird and
insane which is traditionally you have
to have a fund with a hundred million
dollars to be able to like do trading
right to be able to like do whatever
you'd you know basic things you want to
do now of course I can just write like
five lines of code and then just be able
to do the same things without any
additional Capital requirements so in
some sense like these systems are fairly
like efficient in this particular sense
because it you know this fact that it's
enabled so unfortunately these things
come as like dual edged swords right and
and you know
um D5 right now is extremely brittle
like we've written some very good
contracts that are very battle tested
and some very bad contracts that are
very not battle tested and you know
these lead to like
silly hacks there's a bunch of ways of
mitigating it the kind of boring obvious
answer is we do things that I throw out
fancy terms like formal verification and
like all of the stuff and it's like
congratulations you could probably give
some no some assumptions uh under which
like this contract is safe and then like
guarantee that
um kind of at the at the higher level
right there is like
you actually just make good mechanisms
that don't have these problems right
that's a little bit harder
certainly but the point is like if we
want to enable kind of the financial
system of the future well we better hope
it's pretty damn secure against like
silly things like this right
um so fundamentally I think like the
like yes right like there's a bunch of
problems with it and this is a crazy
part about like software engineering is
that it's like really hard right
um some somehow you know I feel like
less Bridges have fallen than like or
less physical birds have fallen than
like metaphorical Bridges have fallen
over the past like you know 100 years
but not so metaphorical sorry uh on
chain Bridges
um
but
you know I think at the end of the day
right like everything kind of becomes
like a profession and becomes like a
thing that exists and like you have good
procedures around it about how to
construct these things safely how to
prove things about you know these like
D5 protocols and about their safety and
things like that and so
you know as as kind of an arts and
what's called an art develops right and
like it becomes more concrete and like
becomes more like common for things to
do
um and and therefore you know as kind of
a consequence of that as like of a space
maturing you just like get good right
um but unfortunately yeah the the it's
it's very hard to say kind of kind of in
the interim what is happening and why
it's happening
so thank you thank you for the question
uh for the answer I just want to do a
quick time check so what about uh 12
minutes or so left okay I think we want
to open the floor for questions oh no
students have uh oh that's right that's
quite bad actually
um
be nice and yeah so if you have more
questions uh also
um kitchen will be here after the class
so you can ask to after the class Google
does anyone have any any questions no
question I do have one more question
I'll go all right
there's a lot of different chains that
if I can operate on like but they're
like I know there's a risk of fragment
team with affinity and you watch the
chains like when you do you kind of see
like in the future like
the most Capital efficiency will come
from you on a single chain Center Avenue
or like over time I can be able to
bridge assets so easily that doesn't
matter I don't know do you have any
thoughts on that so I've ever heard that
but essentially
um
right now there's a bunch of protocols
on a bunch of different chains at least
something called fragments liquidity so
as protocols earn like have more Capital
they are like become more efficient they
become more useful
and right now there's the question of
okay if that's true then like why uh you
know do we not expect like one chain to
like accrue all the value right because
if you have like a very little amounts
of money like in a bunch of different
protocols it's like very bad for users
but if you have a lot of money in one
single protocol that's like very good
for users
um so actually I I will dispute the the
assumption that you're making which is
that actually that's a bad thing
um so it turns out a lot of the
protocols that we care about you can do
things like Optimal routing so I can
essentially construct uh kind of a
higher level protocol
that what it does is it it kind of
Aggregates everyone's uh liquidity so
this is this is why it's called
liquidity is like roughly speaking the
amount of money locked in a protocol uh
and then and then it creates this like
higher level protocol that acts as if it
was like the coolest protocol that had
everyone's money like all pulled
together this is not true of everything
so there's no kind of General solution
but it's true for things like
decentralized exchanges which are
possibly the most common application so
I guess since you're asking that
question there's a we have a weird set
of papers on that so you should go check
them out
um but but the answer is you can often
do it and it often it works extremely
well in practice
uh even across chains
so
hopefully that answered your question
okay
um
instruments that are out there
recruiting so why do we need like if
they're going to do that much quicker in
order for those to be moved on so the
question was for a lot of illiquid
assets there is no need for high
frequency trading so why do we need
ethereum to be faster well fundamentally
the problem is that ethereum right now
it doesn't matter if you're trading with
in the liquid or the liquid assets
you're all competing for the same space
on the Block
right so I mean there's like you know
that's the whole reason why
um
you know people bribe validators in
order to be like the first in the queue
right so that's not the only reason
there's a bunch of other things to kind
of go in it but that was kind of the the
simplest to State reason in
approximately five minutes
um so
yeah let's say it's hard to be very
efficient when you have to like compete
with other people for the same like
space in a given block
right um other people do it and actually
they're very good at it
um but it's a different ball game and I
think honestly another thing is for like
these much larger hedge funds the volume
traded is relatively low so the number
of dollars that you can actually put to
work is still relatively low
um simply because like these long tail
assets just don't have that much
liquidity so you don't you wouldn't want
to do that anyways
um yeah I'll let you let you choose the
next
time
so like there was like a lot of like
that invention and
um
actually like the advanced in the first
before
so in your mind what's the most
important thing that you think that
caused like the the booming of the units
of ecosystem
because like it has been silent for two
years and then suddenly like become like
show me and the thumbs is flowing in so
what was the changing moment
so um I mean I got to cheat and I say it
was not actually solid for two years
because you know I was looking at it
roughly by the end of 2018. um so yeah
if if you were around for what you know
as colloquially known as defy summer it
appears as if kind of uniswap and Sushi
and a bunch of you know any millions of
forks
um happened like all of a sudden in 2020
and then like kind of did not exist
before
um
so and and I'll address the banker point
in a second but
um but no no in some ways it was a
steady buildup and then the idea that
you could like construct incentives on
top of uniswap I think made it very
popular for kind of obvious uh
potentially panzonomic reasons right
um
sorry I have to I have to limit the
number of things I save uh to be I have
to be very careful with what I say
because technically I think this is
going online and it's being recorded so
um you know but okay but so that's
that's the that's the first uh part is
kind of to the ex in in the external
part like an ex like to the exterior it
seems as of like things didn't exist and
then kind of in 2020 Summer of 2020 they
suddenly like started existing I'll
debate that narrative a little bit
because it's not quite the case
um it turns out like a bunch of
protocols uh such as balancer uh and
then curve like all kind of appeared
actually kind of 2019
um
regarding the bancor comment is they
had something that
tasted and smelled like you know
automated Market making but wasn't quite
actually did not actually have the the
important part of automated Market
making they were really close
but it wasn't quite it uh and and we can
talk about that a little bit more
offline but let's say technically it's
it's distinct enough that I would
actually classify it as a separate
entity
[Music]
because you've read the papers or if you
are adding me on because you work at one
of these companies
so that's bad all right great
um so it turns out
uh wow holy crap how am I going to
explain this in like less than five
minutes
um it turns out kind of at a high level
you can construct
like mathematically construct certain
protocols where just by like
setting up the math correctly you can
align everyone's incentives in such a
way that people are not incentivized to
lie to you
in particular
I can set up a protocol such that like
you have you know two players one player
is taking one side of the trade the
other Player is taking the other side of
a trade and
um because of that you can make sure
that like if you set up the incentives
just the right way if anybody lies so if
anybody like does the wrong thing tries
to manipulate it tries to cheat they
actually end up worse off than they
would have been by just telling the
truth what's called incentive
compatibility and it turns out in a lot
of cases not everything but in a lot of
cases you can construct protocols which
are incentive compatible and do not
require external price feeds or do not
acquire do not require kind of external
truth telling in order for them to
function
um so okay so but anyways we you I
suspect you already knew that answer so
I'm gonna I'm gonna leave that for now
and then
um I think you had one more question
I was just curious at what point do you
think it's necessary to regulate D5 at
what point do you think it's necessary
to regularly Define at what point does
regulation become a boon for the
adoption of D5 for a broader
like I guess everyday people at what
point do I think it's necessary to
regulate defy and at what point does it
become a boon to regulate
um
wow uh
so I I guess I'm going to give a cop-out
answer to this 100 cop out and I'm like
claiming it up front is that it's very
hard to strike a balance in a nation
field
nascent Nation nascent
thank you uh in a nation field right
where Innovation is happening very
quickly right it's very very easy to
Simply say like something is too risky
or something is too vulnerable or
something does not uh and and justify it
afterwards
right much easier in fact than kind of
like constructing something that works
right and that's what you don't want to
do is the trade-off is is too easy to
make and in fact it's so easy that like
we are constantly in danger of falling
into that
um that's not to say that like you know
obviously like some amount of Regulation
is like you know important right
um the question is one I think and right
now it's unclear
like what like that even means like what
that question is right like it's unclear
like are we at like what D5 will look
like in 20 years like no I don't think
we're close
right like are we have we you know
discovered all of the like fundamental
truths about how to construct
decentralized markets like
I don't think we're close uh and I think
overburdened regulation or overburdening
regulation
uh we'll very quickly Tamp that down
um and that's kind of what you don't
want so but it's it's a hard very very
difficult trade-off to make and the
answer is I have no idea what it is
and then I just checked a 5 19 things
about time if you guys have a question
feel free to
um kind of come to the stage ask
questions and after we also have pizza
meet up so sounds good right all right
thank you good here well thank you for
having me yeah yeah